Boa noite a todos me desculpem aí o
atraso eu tive que ir pro ABC hoje
atender e a gente acabou saind num
horário de muito trânsito e atrasou aí
toda a
programação Boa noite Carlos Boa noite
Rosa Maria Boa noite Fernanda Adriana
Miriam Obrigado a todos vocês por
estarem acompanhando ao
vivo Então vamos começar com os artigos
e depois vamos responder as dúvidas de
vocês Bem pessoal primeira coisa que eu
queria falar com vocês é sobre poluição
Luminosa vocês já pararam para pensar
que a poluição Luminosa pode estar
afetando a sua saúde é sobre isso que
nós vamos falar ser artigo que também é
um artigo muito interessante vamos
abordar um tópico que tem chamado cada
vez mais
atenção de cientistas e médicos no mundo
todo impacto da luz artificial à noite
também conhecida como a a parece o meu
nome mas é a a né aã em nossos corpos né
especificamente em nossa saúde
cardiovascular parece estranho não é
mesmo como que algo tão corriqueiro com
uma luz de lâmpadas ou telas de
eletrônicos poderia ter algum efeito em
nosso coração então baseado em vários
estudos que avaliar a relação entre a
exposição à luz ial e pressão arterial
ritmo cardíaco e até mesmo alterações em
nosso hormônio de
estresse Então vamos verificar que
existe uma correlação entre tudo isso
caminharemos através desse fenômeno
intrigante e veremos como o brilho da
Luz está literalmente chegando mais
perto do nosso
peito então os cientistas
observaram uma conexão entre a maior
exposição à luz artificial à noite e
riscos aumentados de condições
cardiovasculares então números não
mentem a luz intensa e prolongada
durante as horas noturnas foi associado
ao aumento da pressão arterial da
frequência cardíaca além de maior
atividade do sistema nervoso autônomo
espessamento da camada íntima média da
artéria carótida deixa eu pegar só o
óculos
aqui
ah deix no
carro
[Aplausos]
eentão Especialmente na comanda íntima
média da artéria carótida é um sinal
precoce de arterosclerose Então os
estudos documentaram que quanto maior a
duração da exposição a níveis mais altos
dessa luz artificial piores são os
resultados pra saúde mas o que que
significa isso na prática Então vamos
olhar um estudo de caso os trabalhadores
noturnos que frequentemente são
submetidos a altos níveis de de luz
artificial demonstraram um risco maior
de desenvolvimento de pressão alta e
outras doenas cardíacas Então essas
descobertas ressaltam a importância de
considerar as fontes de luz em nossas
vidas
noturnas biologicamente falando nosso
corpo é uma orquestra sinfônica regida
por ritmos circadianos com Maestro sendo
um núcleo supraquiasmático do cérebro
então a luz é um dos maestros
adjuntos dessa orquestra cuja partitura
foi escrita para um ciclo de 24 horas
então a luz artificial pode ser
comparada a uma nota dissonante que
desafina essa Sinfonia inibindo a
secreção de melatonina e desregulando os
genes relacionados ao ritmo
cadano então Imaginem vocês ter um
interruptor que controla diversas
funções do nosso
organismo Desde quando sentimos sono até
como a nossa célula se recupera e se
regeneram então a luz à noite pode
efetivamente ligar ou desligar esse
interruptor em horários inapropriados
resultando em um estado de estresse
corporal que se crônico pode se
manifestar em doenças cardíacas então
não podemos ignorar o contexto maior da
poluição Luminosa que se expande além da
Saúde Humana afetando ecossistemas
inteiros de animais que tem os seus
padrões migratórios perturbados a
polinização de plantas que é desordenada
pela luz noturna artificial a verdade é
que os nossos ambientes naturais estão
sendo saturados por Luz interferindo em
cadeiras biológicas complexas então
considerando as estatísticas a área
iluminada artificialmente no planeta
está crescendo cerca de 2% ao ano então
com isso estima-se que 83% da população
mundial viva sobre algum nível de
poluição Luminosa então esses fatos
sublinham um efeito dominor na saúde
planetária que em última instância
repercurte nosso bem-estar
cardiovascular então o que que nós
podemos fazer para mitigar os efeitos à
exposição à luz
artificial recomendações do segundo
workshop internacional sobre fotometria
circadiana e
neurofisiológica dá ênfase em manter
ciclos estáveis de Claro escuro
reforçando a sincronização dos ritmos
cadian podendo beneficiar o sono a
cognição e a saúde geral na vida diária
Isso se traduz em minimizar a gente sabe
que é impossível eliminar Então vamos
minimizar a exposição a luz intensa
durante a noite optando por luzes mais
suaves reduzindo o tempo em frente às
telas antes dormir então eu sempre peço
paraos pacientes uma hora antes de
dormir Desligar todas as telas ficar
pelo menos uma hora no escuro
notavelmente os conselhos não são apenas
para a sociedade Urbana mesmo em áreas
suburbanas a exposição à luz deveria ser
cuidadosamente considerada para garantir
alinhamento adequado do Ritmo cadian e
prevenção de doenças
cardiovasculares então concluindo embora
haja muito ainda a descobrir é prudente
adotar práticas conscientes em relação à
exposição à luz durante a noite manter
um estilo de vida consistente e padrões
comportamentais alinhados com o ritmo
cadian é uma estratégia importante paraa
saúde do coração certo pessoal então
vamos prestar atenção exposição à luz
artificial à noite Vamos desligar as
luzes uma hora antes de dormir vamos
evitar a tela acesa o tempo todo se você
tiver que Obrigatoriamente usar uma tela
acesa use filtro de luz azul aquela tela
fica meio amarelada fica até um pouco
desconfortável em termos assim de crom
né mas vale a pena para preservar os
seus olhos tá E também agora a sua saúde
cardiovascular bem ess É o primeiro
assunto de
hoje Segundo assunto de
hoje é um estudo sobre ômega-3 e
vitamina D você já me ajudou o quão
seria poderoso os ingredientes naturais
ômega3 e vitamina D para sua
saúde triunfos inesperados em pesquisas
científicas continuam a nos surpreender
e a história de hoje é um testemunho
real disso em nosso vídeo vamos
mergulhar a fundo é um estudo de
acompanhamento de um ensaio Clínico
randomizado então é um estudo de alta
qualidade que nos deixa estupefatos ão
destacando os os impactos desses dois
protagonistas ômega-3 e vitamina D na
incidência de doenças autoimunes vamos
caminhar juntos por descobertas
fascinantes e talvez surpreendentes
então o ômega-3 e não a vitamina D foi o
grande achado inesperado reduziu a
incidência de doença autoimune nesse
estudo específico e que a incidência de
psoríase no grupo que usou eh Ômega A3
foi menor do que o grupo que usou apenas
a vitamina D de
[Música]
dado certo
então quando nós nos propomos a entender
os benefícios de determinados nutrientes
é muito importante olhar para pesquisas
cuidadosamente projetadas o estudo Que
Nós Vamos explorar Analisa vitaminas e
ácidos gros e seus potenciais efeitos
sobre doenças crônicas e complexas Então
as doenças autoimunes como vocês sabem
ocorrem quando o sistema de defesa ataca
o próprio corpo por
engano essa área é de grande interesse
por essas doenças estão cada vez mais
comuns e afetam milhões de pessoas no
mundo todo então dentro dessa dentro
dessa pesquisa identificaram um grupo de
21.900 21.52 adultos com a média de
idade 67 anos então cada participante
foi eh dividido de forma randômica né
aleatorizada para consumir diariamente
2000 unidades que eu considero uma nota
uma dose baixa 2000 unidades de vitamina
D ou 460 MG de Epa e 380 MG de dha que
são os componentes do ômega-3 dos ácidos
gros ou ainda o terceiro grupo usou
Placebo durante um total de 5 anos tá
lembrando para vocês pessoal Eu
geralmente passo 5.000 a 10.000 unidades
por dia dos pacientes para a maioria dos
pacientes então Vale ressaltar a
diversidade do grupo estudado incluindo
17% de participantes negros 88% de
outras etnias então eles foram
posteriormente observados por mais 2
anos após cessado da suplementação então
durante o estudo foi pedido aos
participantes que informassem anualmente
durante 5 anos se haviam sido
diagnosticados com qualquer doença
autoimune Isso inclui psor Artrite
reumatoide doença inflamatória
intestinal aimoto Entre várias outras
Então quais foram as descobertas os Aços
grassos
ômega-3 nós sabemos que são conhecidos
por seus benefícios cardiovasculares mas
sua relação com doenças autoimunes não é
tão conhecida não é tão discutida Então
esse estudo foi um dos que resolveu
abordar esse assunto e amplia nosso
entendimento sobre esse
assunto os resultados então foram
surpreendentes após do anos de
observação após o término da
suplementação os participantes que
receberam omega3 tiveram risco 17% menor
desenvolver qualquer doença autoimune
comparado ao Placebo de fato 60 novos
casos ocorreram no grupo ômega-3
comparado a 80 no grupo Placebo então no
entanto a incidência psoríase foi mais
alta nesse grupo sugerindo que os
efeitos do ômega-3 podem variar
dependendo da condição autoimune
específica já a vitamina D nessa dosagem
que eu não concordaria utilizar para
esse fim de evitar doença autoimune nós
sabemos que ela é essencial paraa saúde
óssea e a função imune embora estudos
iniciais sugiram que a vitamina D
poderia oferecer proteção que é o que
acredito contra doenças autoimunes
porque eu já vi muitos pacientes fazendo
um protocolo de vitamina D em altas
doses ter resultado não são todos
obviamente tem um grupo que não
responde mas nas doses que esse pessoal
utilizou 2000 por dia o resultado não
foi
esse durante ensaio controlado de 5 anos
houve uma redução de
22% no risco de doenças autoimunes para
aqueles suplementados com vitamina D em
relação a Placebo contudo esse benefício
não foi mantido após o período de
observação subsequente de 2 anos então o
risco entre os dois grupos de vitamina D
O placeo acabou se igualando então
curiosamente a suplementação de vitamina
D esteja associada a uma redução de 2%
no risco de psoríase
o que contr com o resultado do grupo
ômega3 né onde houve uma redução
maior tá pessoal então esse estudo
acabou vendo mais result resultado com
omega3 com a vitamina D e para mim a
explicação tá muito clara é que eles
usaram dose baixa Tá mas infelizmente
vos desses estudos são assim eles chegam
a conclusões
erradas devido
a não sei se é de boa fé ou de má fé
eles iando uma dose
inadequada Eliseu tá comentando aqui
você disz que orienta seus pacientes a
ficarem uma hora no escuro tem que
negociar né Eliseu 2 horas seria melhor
ainda
tá bem vamos as
[Música]
eh perguntas de
vocês
vamos dividir a tela com vocês
aqui primeira pergunta da rua Elita Qual
que é o nível ideal do do exame
hemoglobina glicada é
entre é abaixo de 5,6 tá 5,5 5,3 quanto
mais baixo melhor tá então entre 4,8 e
5,5 seria um um nível adequado de
hemoglobina glicada tá
bom Francisco Weber tomar áa o
hidrogênio molecular pode prejudicar
biota intestinal Que eu saiba não
Francisco e os aparelhos de inalação de
hidrogênio tem alguma contraindicação
até o momento eu não conheço essa contra
indicação Adriana tá perguntando aqui
doutor Desculpa eu não entendi o que que
é essa luz azul que faz bem não não faz
bem faz mal a luz azul à noite faz mal
então você tem que usar um óculos com
filtro de luz azul tá por isso que
alguns desses óculos são azuis aqu eles
f na luz azul Ok mas eu tenho um aqui
que não é azul eu tenho um filtro de
óculos de filtro de luz azul aqui que
não é
azul deixa eu mostrar para vocês
aqui esse aqui ó é bright Zone esse aqui
é um filro de luz azul esse ó é um filro
de luz
azul só que ele não é a
a a leite dele não é azul tá até o aqui
porque eu esqueci o meu óculos no carro
lá vamos pro próximo
Pergunta no caso de tomarmos vitamina B1
com propósito de repelir insetos B1 100
mg isso se dará já com uma dose ou será
necessário um período acumulativo para
queal um odor Que incomode a eles acho
que no m 48 horas de uso viu para esse
efeito
acontecer Rosa em uma das lives semanais
do canal uma médica se não me engano
nome é Carolina não tenho certeza ela
propõe o cbd como auxiliar no tratamento
daimer gostar do contato dela mas não
anotei no dia e não consegui localizar a
Live tá no canal tá no canal eu acho
rapidinho aqui para vocês a Live
n
Pera aí que eu
vou mandar o link dessa Live aqui vocês
T que assistir as lives vou mandar o
link da
Live vamos
lá tá
aqui
copiar o link da Live
aqui Pessoal vocês tem que ter o hábito
de entrar no canal tem lá início deixa
eu mostrar isso para vocês pera aí você
acho que vocês tem que ter esse
entendimento
aqui deixa eu parar de dividir a tela
aqui por um
momento deixa
eu mostrar
aqui
Ó você entra no canal tem aqui é no
computador no celular deve ser parecido
ó
início
atenção shorts ao vivo aqui ó desce um
pouquinho já tá aqui o vídeo da da D
Caroline Fontes
tá ó vou colocar aqui no no
chat
pronto tá bom tá no chat tá esse aqui é
o é o vídeo que a gente discutiu sobre o
fitocanabinoides
deixa eu colocar aqui agora
o novamente
[Música]
a as
perguntas Tá bom então Olha lá a Live de
novo su da glutationa haveriam outros
benefícios então naak que não ten na
glutationa por exemplo tem um benefício
que não tem na glutationa que é você
melhorar a fluidez das secreções do
trata respiratório que eu sa groton não
tem esse mesmo efeito tá quando tomar um
e quando tomar o
outro pode usar os dois juntos Sem
problema nenhum tá o nac é mais barato
ele é mais fácil de achar se você
conseguir glutationa sub inol melhor
ainda tá a diferença é que a glutationa
já é
o a estrutura né é um tripeptídeo que
vai ser usado nas enzimas antioxidantes
né e o nac é um desses
aminoácidos então só que a gluta ela não
é bem absorvida porque ela é destruída
no estômago então para usar avoral você
tem que usar o nac e a gruta tem que
usar via
sublingual tá E tem uns sprays lá por
exemplo tem uma empresa americana que
faz a
glutationa micross somada você pode usar
o spray na boca você joga na mucosa
bucal ele ele absorve mas aqui na
manipulação brasileira também dá para
fazer so
lingual ã thgo vi um suplemento para
fadiga adrenal Dr Lan que se chama
adrenal Rescue e contém adrenal and
hipotalamus tício Qual a sua opinião
sobre ess suplementos com tecidos
glandulares isso já foi mais famoso no
Pass passado depois caiu por terra
Porque existe uma preocupação muito
grande Tá em relação a contaminação né
desses tecidos glandulares Então hoje em
dia incomum você ver esses extratos de
de glândulas nos Estados Unos ainda
tem eu não tenho larga experiência com
isso porque quando comecei a trabalhar
com medicina funcional não tinha
facilmente esses extratos aí de adrenal
e de
hipotálamo tá Então na verdade na
prática não tem muita
muita prática né com isso
daí mas dizem alguns americanos que isso
aí funciona muito bem
tá algumas Fontes Americanas dizem que
isso funciona muito bem eu acho que vale
você experimentar e ter sua própria
opinião Anderson Dr alão que teria haver
o uso de gaba na diminuição de arritmias
extrac ventriculares frequentes
benignas por exemplo teria relação a
quais mecanismos poderiam
atuar não nesse caso eu usaria mais a
taurina não gaba tá o gaba ele pode
acalmar porque ele é um neurotransmissor
calmante Então ele pode diminuir
estresse o estresse poderia assim
controlado ter um efeito secundário
diminuição de arritmias mas o Gaba não é
né um dos principais suplementos para
arritmia seria mais magnésio na forma de
dimalato seria
taurina
[Música]
seria também o l carnitina tá Esses são
os principais o próprio binol né com
enzima que 10 também e são os principais
suplementos para arritmia não seria o
Gaba não mas não quer dizer que você não
possa utilizar mas ele não é um dos
principais
Miriam o que devemos fazer para nos
prevenir os efeitos colaterais de
antibiótico e antiinflamatório quando
temos que tomá-los juntos não tem muito
o que fazer no caso você teve que tomar
antibiótico
antiinflamatório Você pode logo em
seguida usar um probiótico né um pós
biótico e um prebiótico para ajudar a
diminuir o estrago que fez mas para
prevenir esse estrago eu não conheço
nenhuma medida que seria eficaz porque
mesmo você tomar probiótico antes de
usar antibiótico e
antiinflamatório e você vai acabar
estragando a flora intestinal depois
então tem que recuperar ela depois do
uso Tá então não tem uma prevenção que
vai ser eficiente para isso
não é verdade que mulheres sem útero não
pode usar
utrogest oral Não isso aí não é quer
dizer que não pode usar é que os
ginecologistas Dizem que o mulher sem
útero não precisa de progesterona essa
aqui é a ligação deles né eles
desconsideram totalmente os outros
efeitos do da
progesterona na saúde pra saúde óssea
pra saúde muscular saúde cerebral né
então é que você entendeu errado na
verdade não é que não pode tá
e que eles contraindicam porque a mulher
não tem útero como se a progesterona só
tivesse ação no útero
tá Seria necessário repetir os nasol
após 15 dias para exterminar os vermes
que eclodiram de ovos muita gente faz
isso tem muita gente que usa ess
estratégia aqui tá então é você pode
usar o bendal TRS dias e repetir após
duas semanas
Sim esse remédio valtrex na bula tem
muitos efeitos colaterais teria uma
alternativa mais natural para combater
herps tem a lisina tá el lisina é o
aminoácido que tem ação antiviral contra
o vírus do herps El lisina você pode
usar de 500 mg a 1
g uma a duas vezes ao dia de 500 m gram
a 1 g de uma a duas vezes ao
dia
[Música]
Eliseu tá o magnésio o zinco e o ferro
eles competem entre si tá então se você
não usar não quelado você teria que tá
usando em horários
diferentes qual mínimo de intervalo deve
ser mantido entre ingestão de zinco e
ingestão dos minerais prejudicados pelo
zinco eu daria pelo menos uma hora de
intervalo tá teve uma live que você
sugeriu tomar suplemento pinheira santa
umas 24 umas Du horas depois da refeição
para maximizar a
sução a mesma coisa você diz para todos
os suplementos não tem suplemento que é
melhor tomar jun com os alimentos tipo
até mesmo as vitaminas lipossolúveis é
melhor tomar com alimento também tem que
manter interval depois de tomar o
suplemento ou somente
antes aí não ficou Claro para mim isso
[Música]
não você ficou esquisito ess Ender aqui
viu
Eliseu compri os benefício de implantar
as Fes de uma pessoa saudável e outra
pessoa não saudável mas Qual o benefício
de plantar suas próprias PR em você
mesmo nenhum por que que você acha que
tem benefício Afinal de contas você já
tem os benefícios das suas próprias
fezes já tem as bactérias boas O que que
você vai ganhar implantando aquilo que
você já tem não sei onde você que leu eu
não sei onde que você leu isso
transplante fezes não é alto implante
fezes são não conheço ninguém que tenha
feito alto implante A não ser que a
pessoa tenha guardado as próprias fezes
enquanto tava saudável e usa Elas quando
tá doente né existe a possibilidade aí
Talvez seja isso que tenha
visto vamos ver aqui as perguntas ao
vivo
elizel fazero uma observação aqui nac
mais glicina uma grande dupla com
certeza tem estudos mostrando que o uso
de nac com glicina É bem interessante
para pelação antioxidante porque dos
três aminoácidos que que tem na na na
glutationa que é o nac a glicina e o
ácido glutâmico os mais difíceis de
obter é o nac e a
glicina mais perguntas pessoal Eliseu
você quer esclarecer essa sua dúvida
aqui que ficou meio
esquisita também tem que manter
intervalo depois de tomar o suplemento
ou somente
antes em termos de minerais tem que dar
um espaço entre eles se não for quelados
né Porque o zinco o cobre o magnésio e o
ferro eles têm competição na
absorção numa live com a dout
Denise ela falou que Auto implante é
melhor que
probióticos aí você tem que fazer a
pergunta para ela né Eliseu porque eu eu
não conheço Auto implante de feses não
eh Pode ser que ela tenha lido em algum
artigo e tava falando desse artigo aí tá
Auto você você quer dizer Auto
transplante né aut transplante não
existe
né então não entendi você vai ter que
fazer pergunta para ela para saber o que
ela tá querendo
dizer boa noite Existe algum tratamento
natural para matar a lava migrans você
pode fazer o trata Ah mas a lava migrans
é que vai na pele né não tenho certeza
se o protocolo da ru da Clark vai
funcionar nesse caso não
viu pode tentar mas eu usaria
antiparasitário normal não usaria
protocolo da ru da clar não
antes de tomar o zinco tem que ter o
intervalo de 1 hora
certo intervalo de uma hora do quê se
você não usou por exemplo cobre não
precisa ter intervalo nenhum porque você
não outro mineral antes e depois de
tomar o zinco tem intervalo também
intervalo de uma hora tanto antes Quanto
depois tá se você tiver tomando os
minerais isoladamente cada um
deles
Doutor eu posso tomar vitamina sem
receita médica Depende se for um
polivitamínico desses brasileiros que
tem pouca quantidade das vitaminas Pode
posso recomendar na fá de manipulação ou
é
só não sei em ficou faltando um pedaço
aqui
alo Berry nectar da foreva beneficia
próstata e rins
aloa aliva beneficia rins próstata não
Não conheço nenhum um artigo fala
isso depende das doses Adriana se for
dose baixa você pode comprar um
polivitamina na
farmácia no sistema digestório normal a
carne vermelha digerida em 24 horas
depende eu digo carne muito mais rápido
do que isso que eu tenho um trân
intestinal bem
rápido TDH é doença é uma
doença é verdade que 30% das pessoas com
TDH conseguem a
cura eu diria mais o controle da doença
né lisel cura É complicado falar em cura
tá não que eu sai o protocolo Coimbra
não cura
DH hoje a Rita não tá ao vivo
aparentemente
né
Então se se é o produto da Forever ele é
uma mistura de Aloe Vera com outras
coisas tá nesse caso parece que aliva
com Berry
né não tenho nenhuma informação que você
vai ser bom para
próstata mais perguntas
pessoal suplimento LT anina faz efeito a
partir de quanto tempo de consumo por
volta de 3 4 dias já tá fazendo
efeito costumo ficar sem comer
carboidratos até meio-dia para não
bloquear o crescimento do GH É verdade
que o GH continua crescendo até às 15
horas caso fix comer carboidrato eu acho
que não Eliseu G é mais um hormônio
noturno tá e pega a parte da manhã
também mas eu não vai chegar at 3 horas
da tarde não Meus parabéns Adriana
felicidades tá desculpa não sabia que
era teu aniversário vamos dar o parabéns
para Adriana aí
pessoal engi três cápsulas de crisina
2400 MG de tudo junto vai prejudicar
absorção de tal maneira eu não eu não
tomaria essa de uma vez não tá eu faria
isso dividido em três doses para você
melhor você aproveitar melhor
absorção não conheço o nome dessa doença
Eliseu Depende se o a pessoa tiver muita
aromatização de testosterona que ou seja
conversão estradiol pode acontecer sim
de aumentar gordura visceral e a pessoa
tem uma aromatização aumento do
estrogênio sem um aumento proporcional a
testosteron
né Que eu saiba não
Eliseu mais perguntas
pessoal
no momento que a pessoa está no banheiro
tentando evacuar não conseguindo por
conta de constipação Quais são os
suplementos que se podem digerir para
evacuar imediatamente aí é melhor usar o
Flit enema que essa intenção é evacuar
imediatamente compra o Flit enema na fç
e coloca pelo anos introduz pelo anos
que a pessoa vai evacuar tá é é um enema
que você compra na famacia chama Flit
enema aí Adriana pessoal te dando
parabéns aí a Denis Alana O
Eliseu adana gostou do óculos Obrigado
esse óculos aqui não é óculos de grau
não é óculos de luz
azul não não conheço esse alimento que
você ingere para evacuar imediatamente
não você pode usar por exemplo óleo de
rícino mas ele vai demorar uns minutos
não vai ser imediatamente
não
como é que é exame para saber se tá
ingerindo soja não fermentada desconheço
esse
exame existe essa suspeita Eliseu de que
se você usar celular no bolso da calça
você pode tá causando uma radiação
né excessiva no seu corpo tá não
necessariamente a próstata em si
[Música]
tá todos não esse exame não revela todas
as bactérias tá só uma parcela delas
chama-se exame de microbioma intestinal
tá é que cada fabricante vai ter um nome
específico mas é exame de microbioma
intestinal a Rosa te dando parabéns
aí uso de probióticos atrasa a
recomposição da microbiota Não não é
verdade
muito variável Eliseu tem gente vai
demorar um mês tem gente vai demorar 6
meses tá e ômega3 sozinho geralmente não
é suficiente para quem tem déficit
cognitivo mais perguntas
pessoal bem pessoal hoje acabei ter
começando muito tarde a Live mas já
estamos com 35 minutos já respondemos
perguntas do
documento mais uma dúvida
aqui no supermercado olhei um pote de
grãos de gelim preto em Natura na
informação nutricional diz açúcares
totais 1,5
g açúcares adicionais zero esses
açúcares totais ou açúcar refinado não é
o açúcar natural do gelim né que não é
o
adicionado aí a Miria também te dando
parabéns aí
Adriana Doutor voltei a sonhar tomando o
azul de metileno e as tonturas passaram
depois que passei a
consumir três pontinhos consumir o que
Adri consumiram azul de mitila é isso ou
é outra coisa que você tá se
referindo
eu tenho sonhado bastante também mas aí
eu já uso azul de meen há muito tempo eu
não acho que
seja por conta disso
não
Ah sim é o azul mesmo tá falando né OK
el luí também tá te dando os parabéns
aí mais dúvidas
pessoal TAM miquinha azul de metileno
ajuda a criança com autismo Sim ajuda
viu não deve ser usado isoladamente mas
ajuda
sim pois é né benefício interessante aí
eh pelo que você tá falando parece são
sonhos agradáveis né não são sonhos
ruins pergunta do
óculos
eu não vi pergunta de óculos sua não
Eliseu até voltando aqui
h óculos laranjas que filtra a luz azul
é verdade que os óculos laranja é melhor
do que tem para filtrar a luz azul não
não
necessariamente não
necessariamente olha Eliseu eu nunca vi
nenhum caso ser controlado de TDH ser
controlado com protocolo Coimbra não tá
pode ser que o magnésio que você usa no
protocolo Coimbra e outros suplementos
pode ajudar mas não a vitamina D em si
tá
para questão de evacuar o uso de água
quente junto com óleo de coco mas não é
imediato Rosa o que ele tava perguntando
é de de para evacuar imediatamente né
óleo de coco com certeza solta o
intestino mas não é imediato assim
demora uns minutos tá
eh então para ser uma coisa super rápida
tem que ser o
enema tá Mas is você tá falando é
verdade
Eliseu volta a dizer já respondi a sua
pergunta eu não acho que o protocolo
Coimbra vai ajudar a TDH A não ser que
está falando dos Suplementos que se usa
em conjunto com a vitamina D que é
magnésio tá algumas vitaminas sim que
podem ajudar no TDH mas não é a vitamina
D em si que tá fazendo esse efeito tá eu
não usaria o protocolo Coimbra para
tratar TDH
tá eu comprei esse óculos na internet na
no Mercado Livre tá Adriana foi lá a
marca essa aqui ó bright Zone tá essa
que é a marca do
óculos bem pessoal vou encerrar por aqui
obrigado por vocês terem acompanhado
desculpe o atraso de hoje semana que vem
vamos começar mais no horário tá bom um
beijo no coração de vocês
n